or hell even if you want a job but you
just want a better job this is what I
would do first
it's been almost exactly a year since I
had this idea for the podcast so I'm
looking at my messages right now too Sam
so five thirteen twenty nineteen so this
is May 13th a year ago I messaged him
you know I got a proposition for you he
says yes I said I'm starting a podcast
it's like how I built this good quality
good guess and I sent him a list of
guests that I had in mind I said I want
the hustle to be the publisher I'll do
all the work you included in the email
and this in your episode if we start
monetizing let's share the economics Sam
says okay deal I said cool I'll send you
the first episode to preview at the end
of this week and then we go back and
forth a little bit and then and then we
started you know I you know the first
thing I did was I went and found
somebody who could edit a podcast by
going on Twitter and writing podcast
editor in the search and I'm looking for
people who wrote that in their bio and
then I found Sean who was an editor for
other people's podcast we made a cover
or we made we figured out a name if I'm
looking at the messages here the
original name that I was thinking was
because I was basing it off of how I
built this so the name was how I got
rich which I decided was way too you
know an accrued or something it could've
been good name it's at least sort of I
don't know get your attention but uh but
I knew I'd have trouble getting guests
on with that name and in fact my first
million also had trouble getting guests
on because a lot of people who were
successful don't want to come talk about
money and they don't want to seem like a
rich but it worked out anyways
my first millions got off the ground we
shifted off of interviews and started
doing more casual brainstorm type
episodes and that's what people
resonated with they liked listening to
something where you know it gets the
wheels turning in your head it gets you
to learn about a new space or a new
business model or a new product that you
hadn't heard of and people like to hear
two people scheming and thinking up you
know new ideas and dreaming about what
could be because there's not very many
product guys to do that and so that's
what I learned along the way I'm like
our stats now we have reached over 2
million downloads so we did about a
million downloads in the first six
months and a little more than that and
then to let the second half and dude I
could have never imagined that we would
hit 2 million downloads in year one
that's kind of amazing I'm like in shock
even right now just sort of looking at
it because I don't really check you know
I don't really pay too much attention to
it because I'm not doing this really for
the listeners in fact when I started
this I told Sam I said he asked me why
are you doing this and I said well our
company's getting acquired where it's
we're in the due diligence phase right
now and it's a lot of either lawyers or
security people looking at our code
things like that I was like it's really
boring I want to do something I can't
start a company but I can start a
podcast during this time and so I need I
had the itch to start something and this
was my something and I'd always wanted
to do a podcast because I like to talk
and I figured this would just be a great
little networking hack you know when I
actually started the podcast I didn't
think anybody would listen to it my plan
was there's all these interesting people
here in San Francisco I want to meet him
instead of just saying hey my name's
Shawn I'm a founder and this company you
want to get some coffee which is
annoying I hate when people ask me hey
can I have some of your time do you want
to get a coffee do you want to do a call
we'd love to chat I'm like what's in it
for me this is awful I don't want to I
don't even drink coffee so that but
if somebody invites me on a podcast or
advise me to speak at a conference I'm
like okay cool tell me more and I
usually say yes and it's weird because
it doesn't matter how many people are
listening to the podcast or it could be
an event that has a hundred people but
still it feels good to sort of be on
stage and I knew that other people like
that too so my goal was this is a great
way to meet interesting people and have
an excuse to connect with them and I
thought nobody will listen to this
except for my mom but I'll build a cool
network of people through the podcast
that was my my evil plan and then I got
greedy once it started growing and now
it's now I kicked off all that yes and
now it's just me and Sam talking but
yeah my perspective change I think
that's a good lesson to in general so I
had one decisive
reason to do it which was this would be
a great way to meet other cool people I
got that out of it and I did you know 30
episodes with different guests would
build awesome companies and then you
know I discovered a different
opportunity as I was doing it which was
hey a lot of people I should listen to
this okay instead of making this about
meeting the guess what if I made this
about giving the audience content that
they like and being you know being
somebody that they listen to on a
regular basis and I've you know sort of
pivoted pivoted from there but anyways
it's been amazing one year one year
since having the idea and that's that's
pretty bizarre I think I'll probably be
podcasting for like ten years that's my
guess because I like this a lot
and and that's been cool there's all
these different things that have come
from it and I think you know if you're
somebody out there who doesn't create
content today it is where I would start
if I was somebody who wants to have a
non-traditional career if you don't want
to just have a job or hell even if you
want a job but you just want a better
job this is what I would do right off
the bat I would start creating content
about a topic I like either interviewing
guests and networking that way or
talking about a subject researching and
talking about a subject that you're
interested in learning more about and
just publishing and just publishing
regularly because you'd be surprised who
listens pretty badass people who saw
this podcast and they reach out and then
opportunities come my way
or investments come my way or whatever
it builds trust in people and the media
of it is that it's low effort right I
record once for one hour but each
episode gets listened to for thousands
and thousands of hours by other people
so you know my one hour
yields tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands of listen to hours and that's
amazing leverage right I'm getting a
multiplier of what's called a hundred
thousand to one on my effort in time
which is kind of amazing that's why I
would produce content and I would it
also forces you to think about content
as a product right so you gotta make
content that people want you got to
figure out how to distribute it to them
you're gonna figure out how to monetize
it so it's a great little mini business
in and of itself without any cost really
you just gotta you know buy a microphone
that's kind of the extent of it it's not
much more beyond that
you
[Music]